The joe rogan experience.
It's fucked up though.
There's diseases that come just from sex.
Like where,
how did syphilis ever get,
you know,
we know we were talking about like swine flu and all these different things that
come from,
from massive farms,
which is a lot of,
a lot of fluids come from,
how's fucking sexually transmitted diseases come from w w who's the first person
to get herpes?
Like how did,
how did that get Kelly coast?
No.
Okay.
Oh,
by the syphilis.
Syphilis.
Yeah.
Fuck.
It's definitely now what is syphilis?
How does it get into your question?
What comes out of your Dick?
What comes up with leakage?
When I was about 15 my buddy told me I had a problem.
He goes,
can you go to the fucking clinic with me would be if we get going to the clinic
after school,
not even thinking about it guys,
let's see him bitches with sores in their mouth and fucking shit leak.
And that was like,
I made a mental note right there.
Like right there.
I was like,
are you fucking around with Pictures Til I'm older?
Well,
this is the,
one of the things that they shut down the porn industry cause the dude right
syphilis and started giving to the,
the marvelous,
yeah.
This is a,
during 2010,
there was four 45,000,
834 new cases of syphilis compared to 48,000.
Um,
uh,
HIV infections and 309,000 cases of gonorrhea.
Whoa.
Karrie is popular.
Which ones get 309,000 cases of gonorrhea
and that's just for those who taught Connery was over his backyard.
Gonorrhea coming on strong.
It's Kinda read the clap.
That's a good question.
Is that the clap?
Gonorrhea is the class.
I would assume it was that
two thirds of a syphilis occurred amongst men who have had sex with men.
Wow.
Most syphilis is gay syphilis.
Interesting.
There are 377 reports of children with congenital syphilis,
which means what children with it.
Yeah.
Syphilis,
a transmitted from person to person.
It's a bacterium disease caused by long.
Um,
it's a,
it's caused by bacterium can cause longterm complications and or death,
not adequately treated.
Sores can occur on the lips and in the mouth.
Syphilis can be transmitted during vaginal,
anal,
or oral.
Sexual contact.
Pregnant women with the disease can pass it onto their unborn children.
Whoa.
Damn you was syphilis.
Syphilis is a motherfucker.
How quickly the symptoms appear after infection.
The average time between infection and with syphilis and the appearance of the
first symptom is 21 days,
but it can range up to 90 days.
Ooh,
did I knew a guy who used to say that fucking pussy with gonorrhea was the best
person.
That is crazy because it was so hot because it was like feverish.
Lee Hot.
Oh my God.
I think it's safe to say that guy.
Just silly bitch.
How many times has he done it?
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Oh Man.
I forgot to read the fucking male whores looking for a bitch with gonorrhea.
First of all.
I'm not here
for a long time.
I'm here for good time.
That was why I did not say it like that.
That's number one.
Get some of that love opposing easily
live Moulton Moulton posts.
There's motherfuckers that love period pussy,
you know?
Oh yeah.
Are you going to do?
I can't even look at that fucking drag.
And what is bloody lane tracking?
You ready to course record?
Oh,
it is already.
What the fuck's on?